Sampling can be a lot cheaper and faster than trying to
sequence a whole genome and compare it to something else. But,
still, random sampling can have it's own disadvantages. For example, let's
try a random sample from a random page of my genome
book, where we just take one letter from the random page.
We can turn the page and take another letter, and then
turn the page and take another letter. And keep doing this
over and over and over again. But what if we do
this for lots of people, and find that most
of the regions we sampled show no difference at all?
We could have compared genomes from all over the
planet, and not seen a single difference, because all human
genomes are already over 99% identical. So the key
is to sample in regions where we know there's going to
be some variability. And of course this is when our
single-nucleotide variants or SNVs are really going to come in handy.
Personal genetic companies like 23 and me don't just randomly
sample the genome. They're actually going to take a million individual letters
of the genome, SNVs to be precise. Regions where they know
even comparing closely related individuals,
they'll expect to see some differences.